we have exclusive new information this
morning in the death of a louisiana
teenager that we first reported on last
month
15 year old kawan charles disappeared
october 30th
his body was found a few days later and
a sugar cane filled about 20 miles from
his home
his attorneys for the family say the
newly revealed audio implicates janet
irvin
who was allegedly the last woman seen
with him
those attorneys now calling for her
arrest
yes attorneys for the family of kawan
charles say
this audio obtained exclusively by cbs
this morning
is janet irvin admitting to a private
investigator she did not call police
right after she realized kawan ran away
from her
home irvin and her 17-year-old son are
allegedly two of the last people
to see the 15-year-old alive
surveillance video appears to show irvin
picked kuwana up outside his father's
house in baldwin louisiana on october 30
the same day he was reported missing by
his parents
in the audio recordings urban's son
tells a private investigator
he and kawan did drugs at irvine's home
there's enough evidence right now in our
legal opinion to arrest her for
a slew of charges ronald haley and chase
trichelle are attorneys for kawan's
family
it was their private investigator who
recorded this conversation with irvin
and her son
haley says when irvin did not call the
police until days after kawan
disappeared
she committed a crime she knew something
was wrong
and did nothing and the fact that she
did nothing it speaks volumes
as to what her
involvement was in this case on november
3rd
kawan's body was found in a sugar cane
field 30 minutes from his home
the coroner's office says he likely
drowned but according to the family's
attorney the water in the sugar cane
field is very
shallow they believe if drugs were in
kawan's system
it contributed to his death we think the
toxicology report
is going to vindicate what we're saying
today janet irvin can be charged with
delinquency to minors
serving minors drugs
the local sheriff's office says they did
not know about this recording and the
information was not shared kawan's
family's attorneys say the sheriff
has agreed to meet and they are hoping
to compare notes we did reach out to
janet irvin
but she has not responded you know when
we first covered this story guys it was
a very difficult one
the parents want answers and they just
felt like the police the sheriff's
office isn't doing
enough well i couldn't believe at the
beginning of this case that the
sheriff's department didn't have the
technology to track the cell phone
just such a basic technology to be able
to go in there and now
you hear these recordings it just seems
like there's been so many missteps along
the way that i have to imagine the
mother does want answers
any mothering father would want answers
yeah